which one of us is the best indiana
jones
carmichael
hi i'm the tom cruise championship
holder niko perringer and i'm here today
to test out which one of us is the best
indiana jones we all love action movies
and everybody thinks they're as cool as
indiana jones the real question is who's
got what it takes to make a cut
obviously don't don't quiet you don't
interrupt him
you know what you just gave me a great
idea ryan if you think that you have
what it takes let's just make sure that
your souls are pure real quick i think i
got a little arc blast prepared for you
guys a little arc of the covenant blast
just gonna blast you real quick if you
melt then you're out of the competition
but if you don't melt then we're ready
to kick this thing off i don't want to
get a sunburn hi i'm illinois jones they
call me organ jones jake i'm here uh
actually my name's not jake in this
video it's kentucky jones all right i
become indiana sure thing kentucky if
you flinch open your eyes follow the
frame do anything that shows weakness
you are disqualified for entering the
competition but stand there and bear it
for 10 seconds
what's happening
[Music]
did i make it you made it
[Music]
you have pure soul but you lose one
point because your hand fell off
all right grant i'm sorry to save you
lose a point but you're still in the
game can't beat indiana jones you can't
whip it rules are simple three things on
the saw horse whoever can knock them all
off in the least amount of whips wins
here's who goes first
jake it's a point all right three two
one
he said i can rip however i want i can
whip up down i can whip to the side i
can whip however i want illinois not
with it however you want look at this
look at look at him swing it
all right back it up
back it up
let me hear that crack
what is oh
this
the sawhorse which knocked the can over
he didn't actually hit the can of salt
so that counts correct i'm sorry i've
made my rules you can hit the cans off
the real power you see please i'm not
one to tell in mr indiana jones how to
whip his canes indiana jones is a
creative problem solver coming up with
solutions no one else can think of so i
have an idea you have to stay on the
carpet illinois stop cheating illinois
on the carpet
[Applause]
[Music]
more time i'm gonna deduct the point
[Music] [Applause]
barely
[Music]
that's the only way to accomplish this
[Applause]
is that what you're expecting me to do
yeah nice
tie game me and ren cause i'm all about
that inventing this jake caught that
whip his fast reaction's always
observant showing that he might have a
spark of what it takes for indiana jones
and then ran of course showing that he
definitely has a spark for what it takes
for ambien and jones for winning the
competition sam's at zero right now
hello and welcome to round three of the
tournament of champions that's right
we're back again and this time to fight
for the honor of all honors to represent
lady squarespace if you haven't been
watching the last few tournament of
champions here's how this works the
winner goes to a final tournament where
they'll face off against three other
contestants for the right to win honor
for that brand please leave a comment in
this video if you use squarespace or you
sign up because of this video because if
either carmichael and i win in the final
tournament of champions we get to pick
one person and we get to pay for your
squarespace the only way we're gonna
find out who that person is though is if
you leave a comment in this video
squarespace free for all the rest of
2019 i'd say that's a pretty good deal
welcome to
uh what what month is it we who are
about to die salute you king sam wait
why do you have a crown
because i'm a duke and another i'm a
duke in another land
[Music]
you scrapped me on my leg
[Music]
[Music]
squarespace has an all-in-one platform
where you can claim a domain build a
website sell online and market your
brand
round two round two
paul bunyan
squarespace has beautiful designer
templates and award-winning 24 7
customer service
[Music]
i knew this thing would pay off sooner
or later squarespace has fantastic
marketing tools so if you need to create
a campaign reuse templates check metrics
you can all do that on their site it's
wonderful
and good
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my artery ah i bleed it out
[Music]
squarespace has an amazing domain
experience you can transfer your
third-party domains to squarespace if
you so desire
if you want to be a meditating master
and win your own acts head over to
squarespace.com corridor crew get 10 off
your first purchase remember to leave a
comment because the tournament of
champions is gonna be one heck of a ride
king sam he's definitely gonna be there
indiana jones's worst nemesis german
nazis
secret german nazis these three cards
i'm going to dish out one of them is the
traitor card whoever's the traitor is
the secret german nazi when you are
confident shout it out so one's a nazi
the other two are not nonsense you got
it
tom cruise final answer tom cruise final
answer budget adam savage final answer
i'm not the nazi oh
i am not the nazis
hold on indiana jones actually never
gets this right so therefore the ones
who guessed incorrectly get the point
i literally can't argue that
jake is in the lead with two points
seven renault todd is one point it's a
close game
it's time for my favorite game the
boulder run challenge we had to harness
some cutting edge technology and really
push ourselves to figure out how to
simulate the boulder from indiana jones
that's a boulder
dr jones's the rules for this game are
simple start down here with your hand
touching the wall get down there grab
the idle make it back and whoever makes
it through this doorway in the least
amount of time wins the only twist is
that there's a boulder that's gonna
chase you the moment you grab the idol
good luck you guys need some luck you're
the one with the one point
three two one go
are you guys okay oh yeah yeah yeah it
just lost control about here we both
went down and i couldn't get the shot
sam was too fast you're up next kentucky
and i just fear that ren's gonna get out
before that
three two one go
red yeah 9.8
come on carmichael
come on
that means we got a tie game going into
the final round here final challenge
guessing the weight of the idol it's
kind of like price is right but instead
of the price you're guessing the weight
the thing is you have to be as close to
possible
while being just slightly over because
indiana jones guess it's just slightly
too heavy no one may hold the idol to
see how much it weighs they may observe
me moving it
tossing it doing whatever with it each
must fill up this bag with rocks to what
they think the idle weighs i will put
this bag on the scale and measure it
after all three have taken a pass and
i've gotten the weights of their bag i
will then measure the idol in front of
all of them and we'll see who got
closest you want to be as close as
possible while still being slightly over
if you are on or below you lose
so i'm supposed to fill this bag
that's it yeah wow all right i'm going
to say 520 520.
almost half a kilogram one pound all
right my nervous system is finely tuned
all right sam is at 390. 390 grams all
right we have all our measurements bring
them in boys that look real close here
we go whoever wins this
wins it all we're going to measure
the weight of the idol if this doesn't
balance it
kentucky's out
oh
too light
just you and me just you and me this is
a 200 gram weight
and his hat is removed oh
illinois jones had 390 but if it's 3.95
he technically doesn't win 350 is 360
370 we're at 370.
and that is just slightly more heavier
just want to say from this point
forwards we all know who the true victor
is
steven spielberg you know who to call
when you're making the next indiana
jones movie it's this guy
yo
stuff me in the fridge for those of you
guys who are sad to see wren walk away
or jake walk away or clint not even
participate stay tuned for the tom
cruise and indiana jones host the jackie
chan special who is jackie chan
don't forget to hit that new
notification button youtube has done
some little changes to it so you should
click on that notification bell see what
happens
yeah what does happen i don't know click
and find out yeah do it